so far nothing of taste it has even a
remote connection to the area nothing
local nothing authentic nothing New
Mexico New Zealand New Zealand lamb that
cards right that parts right our chicken
is piccata is nontraditional thank you
for visiting us here but son de Mesilla
my name is Cali I'm gonna do just a
little music for you this afternoon
Little Rock number from Cher
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
I love the noise in the kitchen I'm not
too sure what's more scary the food or
singing what would you say and thanks
for joining us here yes that's not about
me no she is not share I am sorry
please
raw pork cooked chicken sat next each of
them disgusting what I've seen this
before I've / fine dining it's not the
mold going on there bloody hell
there's no room at the sides - Jesus
Christ them look at the mold on that
this is absolutely disgusting
so the walk in how often is that fridge
cleaned out my trifling twice a week yes
my mother I really got out yes yeah yes
come with me all of you all right
especially owners sounds good sounds
good
oh wow oh wow look at moldy tortillas
there should not be [ __ ] any moldy
[ __ ] food
[ __ ] horrible when was this nice not
Saturday no I need to go smell that need
to toss it I know that shames Thanks
ok no it's not ok what is that to be
taught a black mole what's it supposed
to be Thai chili marinating my chili
marinade bound up has been used in a
while the sauces was from a chef that
had been there like in 2006 or 7 or
something
is it exactly the same way as you run
this hotel you don't give a [ __ ] I give
you [ __ ] I give a [ __ ] hey this is your
dream of running a hotel
bonus what we are this is [ __ ]
unacceptable and it's not gonna happen
anymore
have you checked out because you should
do it take these two [ __ ] it I checked
out he's talked checked out all right
obviously I need to pay more attention
and do better at my job how many of you
can run a business jibber see three CEOs
three general managers Oh three
Executive Chefs ah it's like it's nearly
ten o'clock when many hotel guests will
be thinking of heading to bed but the
music concert is just about to start
we've been doing this for 20 years we've
been playing music I think Gordon's
gonna like
[Music]
[Music]
I don't do drugs
so never thought I'd see a dancing
mushroom but I was wrong it's like the
Summer of Love these people are weird
but they sure are friendly it's insane
how guests are trying to check in over
this racket if I had arrived to this I
would have gotten on the first plane
back home I don't think I'll be able to
relax here I can't really escape so
Wow and the longer the music goes on the
more guests complain
[Music]
you know what it's on me tonight okay
we're gonna make you happy no matter
what okay with Joanna giving away
women's for free the lodge is losing
money pushing this hotel further into
debt it's way past midnight and with a
band finally wrapping up it's time for
me to get some sleep before I dive under
those covers I'm dying to see what's on
top of them that is disgusting
I am NOT putting my head on that pillow
oh I just touched that it's like a
mosaic of semen look at that disgusting
look at the lampshade and look at that
how can they charge money for people to
sleep in this filth wow this is
definitely a night for my sleeping bag I
[Music]
try to sleep above night
holy [ __ ] window this is crazy
hi guys hi I'm Steve Dexter Steve good
to see you but yeah well I'm gonna see
you too but I'm trying to get a grasp on
what I've just eaten I know you the
owner yes but you're the head chef as
well buzz we're working together down
into him so you're both had chefs I'm
not I'm not exactly sure where I fit in
it's not my menu I'm not doing any
ordering filled with Cyndi right now a
little thrown under the bus I feel a
little betrayed right now
the risotto was sweet with what's in
there apple juice apple concentrate sure
Apple concentrate in a risotto yes sir
come on it's about my menu chef so this
is all you're doing then
yep
oh my god the relaunch of the hotel
Chester is a huge success kicking with
me please yeah now Sookie and David are
on their way to making this hotel the
talk of the town here in the car place
but before I leave I have one more
surprise for them
right there's one more little thing I'm
going to show you in this place
beautiful and gorgeous pool they're both
you come in for two seconds
[Music]
now living in that tiny room with no
windows is not the way to live so this
is your new apartment I rented this for
the next six months I'm sure when the
business kicks off you'll have
sufficient funds to render spawn oh I
love it I complain kitchen lounge how
pretty look at the bedrooms through
there beautiful this is just what we
really need it for day and me to get
away some time out that's yours
thank you thank you again that's awesome
I'm just damn flabbergasted actually
being on sites and not having time out
of your hotel you were blind to the
potential on your doorstep
was ridiculous we thought Gordon was
just coming here to help us with the
business he ended up being helping us
emotionally our marriage he very much
wanted for us to be together and that
was so lovely I've heard em all so no
question about really really nice yes
thank you again now I'm gonna hurt you
okay
I'm gonna spend some quality time
together now you deserve good night and
good luck
all right bye Gordon